certains champions sportifs sont des
ennemis jurés
mais la pire des rivalités a mis aux
prises deux boxeurs réseau et kid
ils ne se sont affrontés que deux fois
mais le match décisif n'a jamais eu lieu
je vous annonce que je mets fin à ma
carrière de boxeur professionnel ya une
boîte qui va organiser le match retour
officiel je vous paierai cent mille
dollars
je ne peux pas être dans la même pièce
que lui 100 euros le coffret regarde la
tronche de ta baraque dis pas que ça
vaut pas le coup je me retape trois
questions je suis un dinosaure
on se marre à une dernière fois et c'est
un entraîneur mike et tu peux pas être
mon entraîneur peut-être que tu l'a
bouffé mon entraîneur c'est l'heure de
s'entraîner que ce qui m'a pris c'est de
la démence au m2 michel raison suis
grave que les jeunots qui lâche tu es
gras pour pâques goguette mois soit
france si l'un des deux va au tapis
est-ce qu'il peut appeler à l'aide pour
se relever et en train de me rendre
dingue il était comment jésus je me
demandais il était cool fait d'un temps
un sacré tempérament quand tu seras
pubères toi dis moi oui c'est notre
dernière chance d'y mettre un terme une
bonne fois pour toute le monde entier
suivent notre gueule mais on n'est pas
morts
au contraire tout ça ça m'a fait me
sentir plus vivant que jamais
vous pouvez vous entraîner autant que
vous voulez c'est plus votre tapis vous
ce notre maximum
d'impôt mis de soutif c'est gonflé su
aller chier devant ta porte
on est en direct mais combien direct en
ce moment
et qu'est ce que tu fous on est juste de
lui s'acheter à manger était pas forcé
de taper sur tout ce que tu vois